[Music]
the united states has confirmed its
first case of the omicron variant of the
coronavirus in a vaccinated traveler who
returned to california after a trip to
south africa omicron has now been found
in two dozen countries infectious
disease experts are still gathering data
on the mutation
we expect to have more information on
transmission
within days not necessarily weeks
now scientists around the world are
racing to find out
whether omicron is more dangerous than
previous strains of covid19
[Music]
welcome to your covert 19 special i'm
chris coburn berlin it is still unclear
what kind of risk omicron poses
and how effective vaccines will be
against the new heavily mutated variant
the measures to contain the spread
though are familiar many countries are
sealing their borders despite the world
health organization claiming it'll help
very little and dutch scientists saying
the variant was already in europe before
it was first detected in a traveler from
south africa
hunting down the variant since omicron
was first reported the netherlands has
tested airplane loads of people health
authorities also increased the
sequencing of older samples from
patients with the coronavirus and found
at least two cases of armacron in europe
before the variant was first reported on
november 24th
the issue is that at the moment a new
variant emerges and is announced
probably the spread is already or the
variant is already spread all over the
world i mean in in the way this this
this variance of the corona virus spread
there is no way you can stop a variant
from spreading globally so
there's more evidence omicron has indeed
traveled across the globe brazil has
confirmed it has identified cases of
omicron the first in latin america
brazil has been hard hit by the pandemic
with more than 600 thousand deaths its
vaccine campaign has finally brought
back some normalcy
i am really worried because although i
am vaccinated i don't know if the
vaccine will help me or not and in case
i get it whether i will have a strong
reaction to this new strain or not
scientists are still investigating how
dangerous the variant is it does have a
high number of mutations some are
similar to the delta variant but even
against a new variant old methods still
work
how do we address omicron we've said it
over and over again and we and it
deserves repeating if you're not
vaccinated get vaccinated get boosted if
you are vaccinated continue to use the
mitigation methods namely masks avoiding
crowds and poorly ventilated spaces
choose outdoors rather than indoors keep
your distance wash your hands test and
isolate if appropriate
stopping amicron seems impossible it's
been detected in a growing number of
countries health authorities can only
hope to slow down its spread
for more let's bring in julian tang he's
a virologist at the university of
leicester in the uk welcome back to the
show julian many people are concerned or
even frightened by the emergence of
omicron how concerned are you
all right so um
you need more data but at the moment i'm
not that concerned for a couple of
reasons one is that the south african
reports of the clinical severities are
actually quite mild
and the reason that i'm less concerned
with that kind of report and i know it's
early days yet is that if you have a
very transmissible virus it escapes the
vaccine and protection but it doesn't
cause severe disease as we see with you
know lots of other respiratory viruses
every year and it doesn't really matter
so if we're getting like lots of cases
like 100 000 cases a day but
say
100 people need to go to hospital
that doesn't really matter to most
people and in fact for flu only a few
people get vaccinated because they're
the most vulnerable and they're in that
hundred that needs to go to the hospital
but the rest of us don't get vaccinated
against seasonal flu and in a way if
that is what's evolving with omicron is
it's actually a good thing because then
we'd have to worry about vaccine roll
out equal distribution across the world
because the virus is actually evolving
towards more benign phenotype a benign
kind of type of virus that doesn't cause
so much trouble in humans and that would
then obtain the need for vaccination so
so julian there are early indications uh
suggesting that omicron may be more
contagious and do i understand you
correctly you think that all right it
may be more contagious but also maybe
less deadly
yeah so the early reports we're seeing
from not just south africa we've seen a
couple of reports from hong kong and
elsewhere where cases that have been
identified have actually been very
mildly
very mildly ill or actually asymptomatic
if that trend continues and we don't see
this these other complications like loss
of taste and smell if there's no lung
covered if there's no pims complications
in children then we may be seeing a more
benign virus that's more like the other
common cold coronary viruses that we
already know about
so what are then the next steps to find
out more about this variant
so we do what we've always done with
these variants you look at the lab data
look at the vacuum escape capability of
these viruses in vaccinated sera you
look at the epidemiology and how the
virus is spreading across different
populations but for most for me most
importantly look at the clinical
presentation the clinical presentation
is just like a flu-like illness with no
complications no unusual presentations
like loss of taste smell tinnitus etc
then you're dealing with a common cold
virus essentially against which most of
us don't need to be vaccinated against
and that's that's that's hopefully what
it's going to evolve into
okay what is the time frame we're
looking at here when it comes to these
examinations
so again as with the previous
delta beta alpha gamma variance etc uh
the lab testing in vitro
will take several weeks to maybe a month
or two it's more difficult with this
omicron variant because there are lots
of mutations in the s protein and that's
harder to create in a in a lab-based
strain of the virus pseudovirus for
example
you need a lot of people to be infected
for that to be looked at and modeled and
then you need the clinical presentations
and we need to pull all the clinical
data together from different countries
again that needs a lot of cases so
you're waiting unfortunately for more
cases to occur before you understand
what's going on
julian obviously
getting vaccinated is still a big factor
as of now and as we've also heard uh in
the report now the head of biontech says
their vaccine will most likely have a
strong efficacy against omicron the head
of moderna was less optimistic what is
your expectation
okay so i expect that the vaccines will
still work to some extent exactly how
much we need to see the real world data
even the lab-based data can usually
underestimate the vaccine efficacy
because the lab-based data just looks at
one aspect of the vaccine response it
doesn't look at the whole
human host immune system response to the
virus
and i think that
this kind of prediction of you know
routine vaccinations every year going
forward we really have to see how much
the clinical data tells us about how
severe this disease is
we see countries sealing their borders
stock markets tanking the head of the eu
commissioners underlying saying prepare
for the worst hope for the best does
omicron deserve all the attention it is
getting also in comparison to delta
which is the prevailing problem in most
countries
it's hard to say i mean if you look at
the early data from south africa you
know spreading more rapidly than delta
but seems to be more benign than delta
then i see that as a optimistic kind of
hope
rather than the pessimistic kind of doom
and gloom i'm normally quite pessimistic
and quite uh
you know half glass half empty rather
than half glass full sort of guy but i
think with this report of loss of taste
and smell not being present
i'm thinking that oh this might be
a sign that virus is actually adapting
better in a more benign way to the human
host population and if we don't see
those complications don't see long
coverage going forward seeing more cases
that actually don't need hospitalization
overall
that may be better than delta
julian according to the world health
organization around 60 countries are
implementing travel measures to guard
against omicron but the who also says
blanket travel bans will not prevent the
international spread why not
well we know this already normally by
the time you've identified the new
variant as with alfred delta
is already spread and we've seen that in
the uk as well people seeing it
elsewhere like south america
north america and southeast asia and we
know this that
detection has always delayed
behind transmission especially with
opening of all international borders in
some countries that like the uk has been
doing in the last few months so i expect
these this omicron's already in most
european countries and north south
american countries as well as southeast
asia already it's just it just has to be
picked up and it'd be picked up after
some amplification in those populations
and we're going to see the next few
weeks probably through to the new year
julian dang virologist at the university
of leicester thank you for talking to us
thank you
and we apologize for the problems that
we had with the line there
a lot of open questions about the
omicron variant scientists have a lot of
examining to do and one of your
questions regards just that here's our
science correspondent derek williams
how does a sample analysis laboratory
distinguish between variants
since the announcement that south
african scientists had identified the
new variant that the who has dubbed
omicron
a few people have asked how they were
able to do it so
today
let's take a closer look at a absolutely
groundbreaking technology that in the
last
30 years or so has changed the life
sciences
really more than any other
genomic sequencing
now
like living organisms viruses carry
around all of the information to make a
new virus
in their genetic code
in the case of source cov2 that's a long
strip
of coiled rna made up of around
30 000 chemical subunits called
nucleotides
together they encode for the 29 proteins
that are produced in an invaded cell
to make more copies of sars kobe 2.
now if that code changes
a process that we call mutation
it can therefore also change how the
proteins are structured
what the who calls variants of concern
are mutated versions of the virus where
changes in the code
have made its proteins more effective in
some way
so to distinguish between variants in a
lab all you have to do
is read the genetic code in the viruses
in a sample it's different and it's
identifiable for for every variant
reading a genetic code sounds simple but
developing the systems to do it um was
not we've we've only recently improved
the process
to a point where it can be performed
quickly and accurately enough
to do things like um detect and track
virus variants as they spread
the current generation of systems called
high throughput sequencers they've only
been available commercially for about 15
years
and detecting viral variants is is just
one thing they can do the ability to
detect
genetic similarities and differences in
species
and in individuals
has impacted fields from evolutionary
studies to personalized medicine
in really fundamental ways
you